[Music]
two
[Music]
hello hello
we are here it is monday
[Music]
the world is ending but you know we
never missed a show
that
a little thing like the world ending
ain't going to stop this kidding
nothing will short this stop the show
short of pure
annihilation that's right human life is
going to have to cease to exist before
we miss a show thermonuclear war nothing
short
skynet maybe more a few more mean
comments and i might disappear forever
though
oh yeah uh thank you by the way to hello
fresh
to thank them quickly at the top here up
guys
you guys have seen abey's burrito right
it says we have to share a dish so yeah
okay do we have no problem absolutely
guys
here's one delicious meal i've tried
through hello fresh
man if only you knew what was inside
with over 50 menu market items to choose
from every week you'll never get bored
get 16 free meals plus 3 free gifts with
code h3tv16 at hellofresh.com
h3h3tv16 maybe show a real meal so
they'll be like yo don't show that
burrito okay uh
here that hurts
our girl
anyways um
[Applause]
yeah
you know
it seems like a lot of the audience hate
me but i'll tell you who really does
hate me who's that dan
why oh [ __ ] because i was gonna be here
at two eight i was gonna be at 2 p.m on
time and dan goes oh yeah well i changed
it to three because your ass is always
late
which is true
but i was going to be on time today i
wouldn't but then i was like i hate
that's love i'm looking out for you man
but then i was like well it's not about
being late it's about being on time so
now we're 45 minutes early and people
are going to be mad about that they just
want to be you know what i mean do you
think they want us to be on time they
want to be on time not early
correct early is better than on time
not for a show not for a live show
you know if you want to if you went to a
uh let's say you went to see hamilton
and you get there at eight and they're
halfway through the show is that good or
bad well
people need a quarterback i'm gonna keep
my opinion to myself on hamilton
yeah
anyway
welcome welcome guys
we're doing call-ins today the crew is
all back in studio
well except for cameron who's still
quarantining and love and love because
he lives with them
but we are doing collins 808 hot meme
if you guys want to call in share some
tales
whatever you got
cameron's going to be doing a live covet
test from home today
that's
right wow stuff how exciting he says uh
he says he's um feeling a lot better so
uh hopefully it will be negative cameron
here you got the test ready this is yeah
now this now this is thrilling i got my
federal uh
free test right now
can we watch you swab your nose
sure yeah i'll do that that's that's
always the wrong stuff
okay now people criticize us for our
content not being exciting well
here we go go ahead cameron 15 15 in
each nostril all right timer on the
clock please do you want to do the
honors of counting down for me
three
two
one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten deeper
get in there get in there where's the
deeper sound bite zach
touch your brain yeah deeper there it is
you're not swirling
all right well
as cam continues with this test
all right
both nostrils there keep us updated and
now you have to put it in the back of
your throat
just kidding
i'll check back in 15 about this all
right exciting stuff wow riveting
wow wow wow wow
so um
yeah apparently everyone hates me now
that's not true that's it's not true
well
not everyone no
no
not me av doesn't
thank you ap dan doesn't
outside the studio
well anyway you know people got i don't
know what's going on i don't know how
serious to take it when people get like
this
i think it has to maybe do with us
talking about
with us falling below 3 million and then
everyone took that as an opportunity to
be like the dog pile the show is
crumbling which by the way
guys if you like the content you're
seeing today like subscribe hit that
bell for notifications so you know one
thing new episodes going on that's right
three times a week monday wednesday and
friday we go live on we go live anytime
between 12 30 and 3.
there were a lot of comments people
saying i've been a fan for years and i
just honestly didn't think to subscribe
because i see it in my notebook i
honestly i did see some comments like
that
thanks for subscribing you are watching
the h3 podcast we're going to give it a
live here today
all right it's monday february 28
2022
head on over to hit that subscribe
button alright just smash that bell
[Applause]
drop a like below a comment below tell
us what you think
all right
if you're a human being hit that
subscribe button that's right
right
human beings only
smash that like button no but um a lot
of people came out i guess so yesterday
or not yesterday on friday
we were talking about jeff
wittock with talk
and his body there and people were
saying i was too mean to him
so that was one thing maybe i am too
mean you know i reflected on that i
think you know maybe maybe i'm too mean
but i think the problem is that we were
talking about how we wanted to have jeff
on the show
and then i goof on them a little bit so
it's a weird dynamic and that's the
problem i have with these people i'm
ambivalent about like nicaragua was a
similar situation where it's like
i like him as a character and i'm
interested to talk to him but you know
this isn't like
having this isn't like a 100 wholesome
interview like if i was to have jack
black on or something and maybe the pro
or just an example sure anyone yeah uh
this is someone we've had conflict with
right so there's some
animosity a little bit it's a harsh word
but sure that works for now
hate maybe no i'm kidding
loathing maybe
just kidding maybe
but maybe that's the problem is that
it's hard for me to juggle both the
entertainment aspect of having beef with
them and uh
and having them wanting to have them as
a guest
i just don't know if it's working the
whole uh
the whole conflict interview you know
what i mean rather just at this point
interview people that i
100 percent
just conflict-free because
i end up being mean and then you guys
get mad at me
or maybe or maybe i am at being a dick
you know not you guys get mad maybe i'm
being a dick you know
that's what it is
but
you know with jeff for for example it's
kind of hard to juggle because a lot of
people are like
it's split they're like don't jeff is
irredeemable
he gave alcohol to the girls don't
forget don't talk to him and then
by the way a defensible position it's
not like i'm not using that voice to
denigrate
but uh
and then uh the other half is like
you're being too mean you know david
ruined his life he deserves just a you
know it's like okay well i guess i'm
trying to please everyone
maybe i am uh yeah i could be a dick but
isn't that why they want why isn't that
why you guys watch because i'm a dude
i'm a dick
that's part of it a little bit hi i'm
dick tip
i'm i don't think you were being a dick
in the last episode personally i thought
the ribbing that you were giving those
guys was very light
well i thought so too until i read the
chat or i read the comments and stuff
and then um
uh you know
the thing is like i remember
uh i don't know i feel like jeff is
i don't know
i'm seeing a lot of people in the chat
say
did i miss something and yeah i think if
you don't frequent uh places like reddit
or scroll deep into the comments section
it wasn't deep in the comments it was
like the majority or you just don't pay
attention to those things yes you'd
probably be confused because
in the grand scheme of uh controversial
things that have happened on this show
friday seemed pretty vanilla no no no no
in terms of our top controversy yeah
exactly i just went home and like put my
head down in shame it was nothing like
that but i was just surprised by the
reaction because it was like the
comments on reddit on the post and the
comments everyone was just like if you
and then open the floodgates of people
being like this was my favorite okay and
i admit you know let's say this year the
show has been a little lazy
here's the thing i had a [ __ ] baby
i'm not even supposed to be here i'm
supposed to be on paternity leave all
right
you know the beginning of the year
and on this one i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna give it to you guys y'all can
honestly [ __ ] yourself
because
look if you go back to the beginning of
say i guess people just forget what the
the situation if you go back
we had the oliver tree
we had the steamies
we did something else what was it
uh we did some game stuff i believe and
didn't we we did at least one sketch i
think too the valentine's day no that
was actually when we got back which is
it makes it even funnier because people
are saying like i miss when they do
games we did a game
a week and a half ago anyway we came
back out of the year before bruce was
born with three huge episodes that
everyone was loving and i said listen
when bruce is here
i'm not even going to take paternity
leave
because i want to keep doing the show
for you guys but it's going to be
reduced effort it's just the way it is
it's going to be live i'm going to pop
in for two hours and i'm going to leave
we simply don't have the band i don't
have the bandwidth to put in more energy
than that i was up till 6am with bruce
last night i was with him all night okay
so you know
if that's not good enough for you then
you can kindly [ __ ]
juggle my balls
dude [ __ ] you oh yeah oh no ela
but that being said i mean obviously i
do want to get back to doing the show
regularly which is coming up soon but
that's the irony is just last week we
were having discussions about um
because we were originally thinking it
was going to be like this for a few
months yeah of course and just last week
we were like maybe we can find a way to
ease back into doing sketches and kind
of get back on the rails a little bit uh
in the coming weeks
and then people are having a meltdown
about it it's weird it's like you guys
forget that i had a baby like i should i
like i was originally planning to just
take like two months off
all right but i was like no no no we can
do the show
and uh
well then there was like we had a covet
scare and then we got suspended
right at the end of the year yeah you
know
give me a break dude
right
i can't believe
the reaction on friday i'd none i would
have never seen that coming i'm almost
left here i think everything was all
good yeah i was like re-watching it too
and i was just like what the hell is
going on i asked dan if there's if it
was possible that we were hate rated or
something because
there's a little bit of that going on
but i don't know
yeah maybe a little bit but i do think
because there's there's just like
the subreddit sometimes is so exhausting
i love this subreddit because for all
the original content there and there's
lots of positive vibes
but there's just and like again
some criticism is is warranted and good
but
it's just a lot of arguing and [ __ ]
that's just
weird not like
i had i removed this one post that was
like a
14 page essay oh really it was like a 14
page essay about how the show is falling
apart because the views in february are
like uh
55 percent lower uh month over month
it's 14 pages we took two weeks off in
february half the month we're gone we
were gone of course the viewers are also
also we were doing four episodes a week
and yes exactly went from four episodes
a week to three and we took
weeks at a time off
uh so
account for that
that's the thing technical analysis i
actually don't care about the views or
the subscribers or anything like that i
just cared that like i mean i do care
about like the views that people are
watching and it's good but
you know
obviously
the show is
doing a having a quiet moment here in a
way because once again i had a [ __ ]
baby
is that okay with you guys still getting
hate
why am i still getting hate
classic god damn it
but i am happy to announce after we had
a whole uh
roller coaster ride of emotions friday
at the end of the show with the subs
they are passing they were going below
today guys we are 2 165
above three million let's go run it run
it run it
thank you for subscribing where's my
arnold schwarzenegger interview
you know uh
unfortunately we're not friends with his
son
why not why can't can we get him good
with this son to get to close to arnold
patrick hit me up
what did i miss
logan had arnold on oh and i'm like [ __ ]
and here i am i'm an [ __ ] yes [ __ ]
logan paul [ __ ] his redemption arc he's
a scammer i hate the guy and i hate mike
too what do you want me to say you want
me to be graceful no [ __ ] them i want
arnold hasta la vista baby i love arnold
they don't love arnold like i love
arnold we were just talking about his uh
instagram before the show that guy is a
he's got like a donkey and [ __ ] oh yeah
the hell yeah he's got a donkey yeah
maybe we could get the donkey i want it
we could probably interview the donkey
yeah he could definitely get that man if
that if that donkey could talk he'd have
stores
he's from austria right you know what
they do in the austrian countryside
i
don't
i don't know i don't know where they're
going i'm just saying if that donkey
could talk he'd have stories j-r-h n-b-r
oh yeah zach gets my
vibe just the right height
no bucket required that's that's unfair
to the austrian people what can you
think of an example of any austrian
that's ever done something horrible in
in history hitler
who zack which one hitler he's from last
year right oh there was that one
about that there was that one it might
just did that just go you flew over your
head a little bit it usually happened
yeah
yeah
that one guy
that one guy
adolf hitler
yes i don't know what to say but
also in other news jeff and his
how do i not say this
who can't say
where the road goes
listen
i shouldn't
let's just say jeff's not coming on the
show
for good reason yeah and uh
do your own research people
i'll just say it i mean i don't care
he's jeff's friend the guy i was making
fun of
he
is
he he came into
our [ __ ]
gated community
and was filming driving by our house and
saying i got all the info you need ethan
don't test me like threatening me and my
family outside my house so that happened
on friday and it was a [ __ ] nightmare
and uh i had to call the police and talk
to the police about it filed a police
report
and like we had to tighten all the
security at the gate
and i mean so like do so is jeff a bad
guy uh yes
yeah straight up
yes dan
called it oh yeah they called it you
know what is it you know what is he my
best friend anymore no friendship
that was a horrible experience they
think it's funny i guess to drive by my
house and intimidate me i don't think
jeff had anything to do with it just for
the record
but he does put a guy on who's actually
just
willing to do something like that
because i
made fun of him for lifting an iron
or lifting weights during his friend
heart-wrenching story so
just not sure that guy's ready to be on
the internet
also yeah what's interesting to note is
that
so this guy he posted a video to his
instagram stories
one in the daytime of him driving by the
house
and one in the night time
so we did a whole we did a whole ops
situation you see aside that [ __ ] and
then so the first drive-through
it turns out happened
when uh
thursday morning before we ever
mentioned him yep so i was goofing on
jeff the first time you guys remember
and so his homie before i even mention
him came and drove by our house yeah to
threaten me and my family which makes
sense being that the day before
jeff put out that video and said don't
worry about giving us your address yeah
we have i thought he would and i always
said it was a joke yeah jeff goes don't
worry don't send me the address i know
where you live
and we were like why would he say that
like it's not i guess it's a joke
but then i realized oh his friend
actually
came to our house and filmed the front
of it he had been stalking you prior to
you even knowing he existed yeah he was
stalking so then when i goofed on him a
little bit on friday
um he then he came back again and filmed
it again i don't know how he got in the
second time but
we tightened the security now so
zoomed into your windows too in the
video
yeah he showed my license plate and he
zoomed into our house
that's crazy yeah by when you said jeff
you know didn't condone it
i i mean we can't know
if he
was in part of this or anything no i'm
not i'm not i'm not i don't put any jeff
i don't think why would he make that
joke i don't know i think maybe he knew
but they didn't post it until friday
yeah i don't know i don't want to say
i can't say for certain that jeff knew
and i i don't want to put that but like
i don't think that dude should be on
your show bro cause like
like
and honestly what i said about you guys
was just in good fun
and it's not really to the level of
going to someone's house and threatening
them
oh i mean yeah most of us felt for jeff
i mean honestly i was team jeff i felt
so bad watching his video
ice team jeff all the way right because
even though i was goofing on a little
bit i was like i want i i'm in your
corner bro i want to support you i want
to help you with lawyers and stuff and
you know some some silly goofy jokes or
maybe some mean joke let's be honest a
little mean but like for the most part i
was i was team jeff
uh all the way i was gonna help him with
lawyers and everything and then
apparently uh
i don't know very disturbing very scary
i have a loaded shotgun in my bedroom in
a gun safe and i know how to use it
and uh well hopefully he doesn't get
back in after
after that and there's also a police
report filed so
not very happy about it
i was on my way over i was gonna patrol
outside the gate he's a big guy too his
friend is like six too he's like a
monster meat popsicle if you go to his
instagram it's all like he's like super
active sports and [ __ ] like he might
take a shotgun shot and still keep going
kind of guy yeah if i saw him i wouldn't
walk anything i would just
alert the authorities
okay good you're gonna you're gonna post
outside my house i'm post outside the
gate security on security
oh yeah
thank you bro mm-hmm
no it was scary
it was honestly a horrible evening on
friday dealing with that because i was
talking to jeff and i was like
i actually it's funny i talked to jeff
and i was like
hey man you know i'm really sorry uh
and he he messaged me he's like hey my
buddy's really upset about it i was like
you know what i'm sorry dude that was
really mean
will you apologize to him i'll even get
on the phone and talk to him
and then i saw one of the guys was like
hey you need to see this i was like
that was after i already apologized and
was like it's all man i'm sorry i don't
i'm just being a dick i'm trying to be
entertaining but it comes off bad and
then i see this video that he drove by
my house twice
and i'm like
jeff what the [ __ ] is this
he's he removed it by the way so that's
good but
that is wild out of all the beeps we got
on
i'm getting into on the show yeah this
was so
done so much worse yeah i mean
nobody's showing up at your house before
no of course not
i don't want you guys to to
i'm just going to give jeff the benefit
of the downside in now okay that's what
i'm just you know
but
oh yeah and then he posted he went back
to miami he posted something like hey we
really showed those guys
they got the message out there in
hollywood
i got the message bro
i'm not going to talk about you guys
anymore
we got the mess he got the message
let's just
don't be watching the show and
commenting on me
all right i should stop yeah cause this
guy's actually gonna go and kill me
which i do not like that idea at all i
don't like but you see this is the thing
i can't shut my [ __ ] mouth
i wasn't i told myself i was going to
talk about this today but how am i not
going to talk about it
you kept saying in the chat you weren't
going to talk about it yeah but i did we
i i offered the crew i was like does
anybody want to take a bet that ethan is
unable to uh hold back talking about it
nobody would take the bet we all knew we
all
nobody
how am i not supposed to talk about this
it was a big deal man it was a big deal
obviously on friday i was fuming when
this all was going down i'm scared bro
also like
um
you know
well we were debating if to have jeff
well obviously jeff's not happening so i
had to explain why the [ __ ]
this happened
uh why jeff's not coming on
but
all right
i don't know
wish jeff well and all that but that was
not cool all that [ __ ]
lily just said some
goofy
stupid [ __ ]
you know what i mean
yeah forget about it
forget about it
god i want to say so much more
let's just go onward i shouldn't i don't
know
i don't i don't want to uh yeah we have
i don't want him coming back to the
house please don't please that we have
uh a good uh guest that people are
uh actually hyped to have on who when
all right no next week
it's next week it's next week not this
friday not this friday but the following
friday so next friday we have uh
drew drew afraid
i think this is how it's played very
sorry if i'm mispronouncing it exciting
once olivia comes back by the way we're
gonna get her on booking so we can get
honored
we gotta get on honor that would be sick
come on
get down
come on arnold
all right anyway let's get on with the
show okay if that's okay with you guys
hey with me
uh do we have anything quick we can do
before break because we only got about
five minutes or so
this guy these people are so sick man
i'm telling you conservative i'm just
telling you guys i'm not
this isn't a bias this is just reality
conservatives are
oh
they are
a
i know this is a generalization but it's
probably true about 80 percent of the
time i say
they are the most brain rotted
back wood
uneducated
fascist losers
pieces of [ __ ]
uh-huh
used tampon asses
[Music]
okay
look at this guy rep clay higgins clay
higgins so by the way the new the
talking point on the right lately has
been you know putin putin knows which
bathroom to use so
we should we why do i care about
putin putting nuclear bombs in belarus
you know they know how many genders
there are
vladimir putin putin never called me a
racist
yeah i saw some uh comment on twitter
that i thought summed it up nicely that
the culture war [ __ ] has consumed
the gop to like such a degree in the
last few years of like
they know
that that's like their strategy and so
they're just hammering on it it's
they've leaned so heavily into it that
they don't have another metric in which
to understand the world anymore like
this this has nothing to do with trans
people or about non-binary people what
[ __ ] so ever and somehow that like
we're still trying to like frame russia
vladimir putin is invading europe
this has nothing to do with men and
women bathroom yeah
people
how are you supposed to [ __ ] work
along the aisle with people who put
everything in the terms of
of men's and women's bathroom and if
three-year-olds should transition he
goes he goes putin number putin knows
transitioning a three-year-old isn't
right
maybe he should take over the world
so this is a representative clay higgins
you millennial left by the way this is
the biggest ratio ever on twitter but
okay let me read it you millennial
leftists who never lived one day under
nuclear threat can now reflect upon your
woke sky
you made quite a non-binary fuss
to save the world from intercon
intercontinental
ballistic tweets
uh first of all obviously people just
making fun of him for his it doesn't
make any sense i mean the guy's trying
to be like
a [ __ ] he's trying to be like uh
what is he trying to be like like you
thing seems like emily dickinson or
something i know it's like sort of
what's a woke sky you dumb [ __ ]
you stupid [ __ ] here's what's
interesting so i looked up this guy's
age he's 60 years old he was two years
old during the cuban missile crisis you
never lived under nuclear threat evil
you [ __ ] fraud well if you want if
you want to define it as like a crisis
like that or you could look at it the
other way of
we all
anybody
who's lived
since the 50s has lived under the threat
of nuclear annihilation because
that's just a [ __ ] fact of life of
the world now yeah and guess when he was
born
in the 60s right exactly right
we like to troll you know my dad he's 71
when he was 12 he would go
he was in middle school and they would
have to do drop drills where they have
to get under the desk in case russia
nuked the united states right
my dad experienced that you were two
years old okay so don't even try to do
stolen valor with that [ __ ] you [ __ ]
okay and second of all
i love it it's what culture
woke culture
is somehow what's a non-binary fuss
he's
he's a it's a fuss
it's just a fuzz it's a certain type of
fuss
by the way you're the one doing your
bitching on twitter like look at you you
think you're any different you dumbass
stupid ass
dictionary.com we're not entirely sure
what this tweet is supposed to mean and
we're literally the dictionary
i love that quarter of a million likes
i'm literally yo that's such a powerful
um
it's gonna be one of the highest ratios
of all time
quarter million likes to four thousand
quarter million likes to 4 000 likes
yeah ratios don't get thicker than that
boy
yeah but this this is this is the world
we live in but you're right i hope this
starts to backfire because this woke
[ __ ] it's just so stupid like we can
have a conversation
about trans issues and stuff and also
care about a war in ukraine and let's be
honest all these like social progressive
issues that you hate because you're a
conservative christian that believes
that like gay being gay is a sin
it takes up a small amount of brain
power to [ __ ] debate that and think
about it progress is inevitable the fact
that you define your whole party around
this stuff is just pathetic and i hope
it [ __ ] crumbles because they don't
do anything but culture war it makes me
want to [ __ ] [ __ ] and puke at the
same time unfortunately it oftentimes is
effective but
when
we're seeing an example of like when a
real version go dangerous uh crisis hits
like this and you know you've
your entire framework of looking at the
world is uh anti-woke
culture stuff oh [ __ ] yeah you're kind
of caught with your nuclear oh russian
race nuclear readiness oh trans
bathrooms
this wouldn't have happened
so who is
gay also my favorite is being like if
trump if trump was president this would
have never happened you mean the guy
that withheld 400 million dollars and
tried to blackmail the ukrainian
president who's now a hero that everyone
loves yeah
yeah that
because when they did that impeachment
uh
you know i think a big part of the
reason why it really didn't have that
much momentum or any hope of passing is
everybody was kind of like ukraine
where's that again like zielinski why
should we care about this or whatever it
was very much out of the public
consciousness even if it was important
it wasn't something well now we know how
important it was right exactly and now
retro actively i think people are going
to be like oh maybe that was pretty
[ __ ] up what he did well think about
it putin knew he would putin's been
planning this you don't just decide one
day to go invade ukraine
you're talking what was this like a year
ago a year and a half ago
donald trump is
is withholding military crucial military
funding to ukraine who's about to be
invaded by putin
it's a little [ __ ] coincidental don't
you guys think
by the way here's this guy let's see
what he look by the way look at this
chad bro this guy knows what bathroom d
is
my balls dude [ __ ] you how are you
oh sorry i think i
said wait what's happening i don't know
oh i am muted it sorry
persian gulf behind me
i have
god damn it
clay higgins
i got my higgins right here for you but
version golf behind me
high high-level meetings today and
tomorrow
tomorrow trying to get americans i
should make fun of louisiana back home
who were abandoned
in the shameful retreat from afghanistan
are you still bro
the shameful retreat that that trump
orchestrated and planned and
was this is from february 23rd
oops
we're doing our best
our own state department has been an
abysmal failure
uh some of us trying to
get these americans home
oh
superb the [ __ ] was that
what was that behind me get these
americans home
oh
is that something i don't know what it
is
is that like a million maybe it sounds
like you were burping man sometimes like
marines do something like that is that
well they do hoorah no i mean
[Laughter]
this guy's trying to act like there's
not about a nuclear war about to happen
my name is people saying who
who uh
hua is a military thing yeah i don't
know
i'm just i'm just seeing if somebody has
an explanation if there is if there is
something normal
all right is it sponsor time and then we
can get in with the
yeah let's go aoc ratio at his ass by
the way
i'm gonna take this i've sat on a
committee with this guy for years he
talks like this every day
listen aoc with your woke skies
and your blood stain bathroom
watermark sinks
i'm trying to ban the gays in their
house-sitting clouds
and you said to me i don't know
like a word salad
you're woke skye
cam what's the results there are people
saying we we do in the military it means
like heard understood acknowledged okay
that's what i i figured yeah something
tells me when they say it in the
military they do with a little bit more
like energy than just like
it's like the tim allen sound maybe not
all right cameron you got your results
oh cam
drum roll
wait cam is a picture of a dead fish
currently
he's probably a screencast oh he's
screaming here let me ping him if we
want to do that right now but he's doing
what screening calls oh he's screening
calls good man good man
yo
let's do test results
cameron is very nice
cameron
dude some of these colons are gnarly bro
i don't even think i can talk to this
person it's too graphic wait wait wait
which one
number 26
that's probably too gross right
i would like to hear it i mean i would
like it but that might be i'll read the
description it says
somebody who used to be a
s worker
someone paid them 400 dollars to eat eat
the poop
that's gnarly that's too gnarly right
maybe
in the vegas term maybe we could do a
poll so people can decide if they want
to hear it or not so
well i think people
well maybe not i don't know but
regardless it's more youtube are they
gonna they're gonna get no we just have
we have to use our language yeah we
can't say
we just say eat the eat the pea
right we're eating the pea here folks
except eating it
all right cam is here
you really want to do that a.b i think
it'd be very entertaining i like talking
to haters but
if you're and i mean is there really a
hater watching right now that wants to
call him for sure okay i know they want
to call him but for sure watching let me
talk to one of these hater ass [ __ ]
all in i don't
i disagree
i'm down i just want to have fun i'll
hear him hey man let's have some fun
it's fun uh anyway cam what's the
results drumroll please
all right i gotta say there's currently
1 500 people in the busy room in the
middle waiting room on stream so i'll
try to find a hater but yeah no it's all
good there's a lot of folks out there
all right so the test results are
oh man that's like a strong that's a
strong positive this is the strongest
possibility it's been
holy crap but you feel fine i feel great
yeah i feel 100 better today okay that's
good
yeah i i did read on the cdc's website
that you can test positive up to three
months after infection but wow
yeah i
i don't know i feel great today
what's the rules they say once you feel
better then wait five days or something
and then you can go
what i read is like five days after your
first
uh symptoms showing up
and you're feeling better then you can
re-enter the world with a mask and
everything and then five years after
that you can re-enter as normal seems
reasonable
but i mean i'm probably gonna get a
million posts saying i'm wrong about
that too but that's just what i remember
reading on the cdc's website yeah i mean
i think if you
you could probably come back next week
cameron can i ask a question absolutely
yeah are you in a room with two beds
that's
i'm scared of getting dogs
oh no no no no no no no no
you guys are living you guys are you
guys sleep in the same room no
there's four beds in here um
i don't know about you okay so you're in
a bed with you're in a room with two
beds
yeah i don't want to show
because it might be hold on it i think
you love love's off frame that's what
i'd sounded like love is next you're
like no no don't show them don't show
them love is next to you
no
love love is in the air prove it
bro i don't want to get [ __ ] with but
sure i'll show you who's going to adopt
you
see i took my painting down this looks
like a green screen man it looks like
you got a divider or something you guys
we
so it's fun to jump back and forth like
a kid
oh my god you guys comfortable it's okay
though
yeah it's a good apartment i love it
here yeah good good thank you we got we
got two bathrooms oh nice nice nice nice
nice nice yeah camera's been completely
isolated i haven't left this room in
like five days now
you guys ever have slumber parties since
sleep in the same room
no not yet but we should we should build
like um blanket forces yeah
totally
i'll come over and help that's awesome i
thought you guys were sleeping next to
each other that would have been great
like step brothers yeah
i wish we had like a bunk bed or
something that'd be a sick dog yeah
i can get you guys a bunk bed really
it's pretty funny
yeah
all right let's once i'm cleared we'll
talk about it all right all right well
i'm glad you're feeling better cam
keep keeping on okay good news thank you
very much i'm gonna go find some haters
in the call screen now okay all right
sounds good
see ya
all right let's take our sponsors real
fast
thank you to babble
all right
whether it's saving more and spending
less getting organized or losing weight
there's a lot of worthwhile goals to set
for yourself this year at the top of my
list is learning a new language with
babel the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscribers
our young beautiful
supple
stacked in
is learning french
what
supple staff
just means he's young and healthy yeah
okay
thank you
oh oh oh
mercy
oh what about all me
oh yes
hit me with the zack come on to the
babel
i can't with this program oh sorry
oh [ __ ] oh monsieur i'll miss you hello
all right well how's it going you like
it uh ian yeah i've been just slamming
it hot and heavy it's good it's been so
going picked up a lot from the last time
i've been learning a lot
i've been learning the language can you
say can i get
can i have a croissant or do you have a
croissant can you say something like
that
uh like i'm eating a croissant like can
i put like you're ordering a croissant
uh
uh
um
look at that
wow
not only is learning a new language a
fun engaging new hobby you can use it
while checking off travel more from your
list and the whole bible process is
addictively fun fast and easy babel
teaches bite size language lessons for
real world uses babel's 50-minute
lessons make it a perfect way to learn a
new language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lessons
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts the teaching
methods have been scientifically proven
to be effective and with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian german
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent there are so many ways to
learn with babble and additional lessons
you can access podcasts games videos
stories and even live classes plus it
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
so start your new language learning
journey today with babylon right now
save
up to 65 percent off your subscription
when you go to babel.com h3tv that's
babble.com
h3h3tv
for up to 65 off your subscription
babble language for life
and finally
you know them
you love them
it's hello fresh with hellofresh you get
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip the trips to the grocery
store and count on hellofresh to make
home cooking fun
easy and affordable and that's why it's
america's number one meal kit
let's we can skip the burrito today we
already did it
think about it how yeah this look this
is a brand new one
looks good what is that chili one pot
beefy taco soup oh i love the one pot
yeah
we should get some new ab burritos
maybe
maybe make a new burrito okay and then
send us a picture but not cut or
anything okay we just know that there's
something new in it we have to take my
word
we don't know he actually did that the
other day
what who did that maybe did
are you serious yeah here's a picture of
it
that's
no that's the same burrito that's a
different one
it looks the same to the same place yeah
you see the shrimp [ __ ]
that looks good
that's the thing about hellofresh they
send you the all the ingredients
pre-portioned with a little info card
that tells you about all the ingredients
how to cook it it's basically so easy
and the food is always so delicious and
fresh
i love it because i always learn a
little bit you know
actually stepped up my meat grilling
game quite a bit from using hellofresh
and
learning from their cards the cool thing
about it is that it's oftentimes it well
here i'll put it this way 72 cheaper
than a restaurant meal of the same
quality and on average you save 65
dollars per month when you order hello
fresh instead of grocery shopping
that's crazy
and they've got 50 menu and market items
to choose from every week including
veggie fit and wholesome
family friendly and gourmet options
providing plenty of variety
go to hellofresh.com h3tv60 and use
called
h3tv16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts that's hellofresh.com h3tv16
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit thank you
thank you thank you
what do you guys think you think uh
nuclear
all of the nuclear wars are coming
fallout
sam does
sam really does she's a little bit
afraid of it
that's segway
that's sponsored so anyways is life as
we know it ending in the next couple
weeks
uh i sure hope not i mean it you
certainly can't say
there's zero chance because there is a
lunatic uh with you know six thousand or
so nukes i don't think putin was as
crazy as he was but this whole ukraine
thing is proving him to be quite quite
unhinged i mean the the plan of
encrypting ukraine has spectacularly
backfired so far i mean he's just taking
the biggest l in every way possible so
far i mean it is still very very early
uh this war has been going on for what
four days five days now um so
yeah and i've seen a lot of analysts say
that um
that russia is clearly holding back um
because likely because their intention
is to to govern ukraine ultimately they
don't want to destroy it but if they
continue
to get stalled out the way they seem to
be i wouldn't be surprised if it starts
to escalate to leveling cities and [ __ ]
and um
at that point
things could go south real quick i mean
not that they haven't gone south but
further oh you're right you're right
because right now it's like small
skirmishes and stuff and a lot of people
thought that the russians would just
come over and take the city in a day
like it seemed to be what they thought i
think they thought everything it was
just going to collapse uh almost
immediately and that hasn't happened so
i don't know you know in truth i think
the russian soldiers they just don't
want to be there they don't care they
don't want to be there they don't want
to fight you know there's over 5000 poor
poor russian
young man who went there to die for no
[ __ ] reason 5 000 over 5 000. i mean
that's just staggeringly sad
and so pointless so i just think
also i don't think their army is as good
as as maybe we thought it seems like
they're just
their hearts not in it man
but they do have the capacity to destroy
the whole i mean they're way way bigger
country they have their military is far
far bigger and it's becoming pretty
clear that you know the west isn't going
to become directly involved which
i hate to say it but is a good thing
because if we go to war with russia then
yeah this shit's going to get real bad
for the whole [ __ ] planet so
it's um yeah it's just i think the west
is doing the right thing i do not want
to get into involved in a war i want to
go to war with russia that does not
sound fun
no
i live in los angeles we're we're
getting hit when the nukes start flying
we're getting hit so you think so
yeah i mean it's a major city
what about me and bel air i'm outside
the city enough
it's just i mean is it one nuke in
downtown or is it there or
la they're gonna that's what i'm saying
they're gonna clean the whole yeah i
don't know that is the valley uh
involved in that too
i don't nobody cares enough about the
value you'll be fine cool thank god man
but it's you know if they're gonna if
they're gonna
anyway
i still have faith that america has
space lasers that can [ __ ]
blow up all the nukes in orbit oh well
they certainly have some of those but do
they have
do they have enough to stop you know a
thousand of them flying out of the
country at the same time i i don't think
so
also
sorry go ahead i was thinking chantal
was having a panic attack about this
last night too much like sam and i i
said the same thing dan like we would
take those [ __ ] down
yeah
submarines pretty close that's the thing
too is like the lasers can shoot down
the uh
the icbms but um
submarine launched ones you know are
well don't we have sharks with lasers on
their head and [ __ ] wasn't that a real
thing you remember that during world war
two we actually trained dolphins yeah i
was gonna say there's dark there's
militarily trained dolphins i don't know
if it was world war ii uh or maybe it
was in world war ii as well yeah
actually i have a buddy who watches the
show so if you're watching right now
dude shout out um who he wasn't in the
navy but he was a marine biologist and
he worked with the navy and he he was
the dude training those dolphins to
find mines and stuff
oh my god those poor dolphins would they
really suicide onto mines
no no no baby
that wasn't their job
causing the
minds no they would they would uh find
them and and seek them out
but if you're if you're worried about
nuke like uh nuclear end of the world
i don't think we're anywhere close to
that to be honest with you
i mean there's mutually assured
destruction and i don't think putin
necessarily
wants to obliterate humanity
but um yeah it is
almost certainly blustering um because i
mean he's well aware
i mean that's a it's a
there's no winning in that kind of thing
like does he want he doesn't want russia
destroyed and that's what's going to
happen if he starts shooting nukes i saw
one
russian person or
someone said on tv i don't know what
their position was but they're in the
government said like
if the world doesn't want us in it then
we don't have any use for the world
something of that effect regarding
nuclear war
i was like
you better ask you
you better ask the people in your
country that
my hope is that before if he's actually
that crazy that there's enough generals
and people in his government that would
uh coo his ass yeah they would coo his
ass fast
before he sure hopes oblitera because
again
the russian people don't want this
yeah i see some people saying like
putin's bad but he's not crazy i
the thing is this this whole thing just
seems so
yeah
weird i would have two weeks ago i would
have agreed with you fully but like this
this whole invasion seems like such a
[ __ ] dumb move that it does make you
kind of question
uh i mean he's getting pretty old
you know a senile little dictator yeah
yeah i agree he's up there
he's been acting really really crazy to
be honest yeah
but
i don't know i also saw online someone
was like
oh he's 69 damn he looks actually pretty
good for his aj
he's hanging in there yep not bad
good for you bud what's your regis drop
your skincare routine
69.
it's all those golden showers
but i saw i saw online someone said that
they're
super liberal person they're married to
a russian
woman and her family back in russia all
support the invasion of ukraine
because of all the state propaganda oh
i'm sure i mean so that was like wow i
don't know pretty scary
but i'm not i'm not like worried so i
don't think you guys have anything to
worry about at this moment you know
hey if it happens it happens what can
you do as long as we have time to beat
eldon eldon ring then
all right now please mr putin don't
don't do it don't don't hit the red
button until i become
i didn't even get to use my great acts
of goddrick yet
speaking of which do we have
we have some thoughts
to discuss do we not do we have what
some things to discuss
do you guys want to hear about that i
feel like the the audience doesn't care
but you guys all i made a challenge to
you guys right i was just talking about
the challenge i made a challenge to a b
cameron and love
[Music]
that if they could beat the first boss
of eldon ring
i give them each 100 bucks and pay for
the game
a b we're doing the ouija board
challenge
i beat it i'm wearing sunglasses because
i've broken blood vessels in my eyes
from not sleeping
it's very addicting don't you always not
sleep
i haven't pulled a complete all-nighter
in a long time so this is uh
actually i haven't swept at all
whatsoever are you loving it it is
really fun i wish i waited till after
my boxing match to play it but
i will still be there
yeah
but you should we have a group chat of
elder boys
because it's fun because i never played
a new
game
from them from the beginning and nobody
knows anything about the game
so it's fun that we're all sharing tips
right right when you went through all of
them
like i was talking to you about it but i
had played them all years ago yeah but
now you're like actually well you can go
online and be like i need to do what's
the guide what's the best weapon
yeah and then love how you beat you beat
him as well are you enjoying oh yeah oh
yeah
well
last time we spoke i uninstalled the
game and refunded it
but when i heard there was money on the
table of course i downloaded it again
bought it again
and i [ __ ] crushed that [ __ ] yeah boy
i i'm enjoying it very much yeah i'm
very thankful
that you gave it another shot yeah the
way it goes
so it goes so
that was the that was the reward the
whole time the money thing was just
that's not that was a yeah i'm kidding
oh actually we have cash for you and
then cameron did you beat the boss
he's probably yes he did he also
he's screening calls but yes he did beat
the boss so everyone i think it's the
best game ever
i truly think
that we are living in the best video
game
timeline right now i think it's the best
game of the decade it's so addicting
i'm glad that you guys got me into it i
would have never thought that's what i'm
saying you got to push through yeah got
to push through you got to push through
it's always always tough at first that's
what i'll say about that
so congratulations i got some crispy
100s for you guys you want to share the
love i want you guys to enjoy this
gaming masterpiece eldon ring
thank you thank you thank you thank you
here let me take a call let's see
uh do we have any haters on the line
um
i'm just saying
okay
okay this is interesting
we have a hater online right now whose
name wait why is your name johnny cash
that's not your name
hello is your name really johnny cash
yeah yeah it is hey i can't hear you too
well can uh is there any way you can
turn it up a little or
i can oh test test
oh there you go loud and clear okay so
ethan uh long time watcher okay first
time caller
i just this is a real big gripe from
like the conservative community that
watches your show because although we do
not have like the most brilliant beings
ever on our side so like blankets under
the statement of like a bunch of like
brain rotten like you know this that
what the [ __ ] do you think you guys are
smart enlightened sex educated
good looking
i said sexy well okay so no but i'm
kidding but let's talk specifics so
who's your favorite conservative let's
start there
okay okay first of all
not stephen crowder okay good that's a
good start that i wish you guys would
have actually debated though that would
have been interesting to hear so do we i
wanted to we all wanted to but okay
that's all that that that settled that
settled law okay so can you guys
honestly tell me that you think that the
direction this country is going is
better under biden than it was under
trump
who's your favorite conservative
my favorite conservative yeah
um
well actually my favorite politician is
paul c gabbard she is a conservative
democrat
i'm not sure if you've heard of her yeah
i know
gabbard not a fan yeah but i i just feel
like
by you like i i get what you're doing
you're [ __ ] talking like the bad people
okay so
so tell me who who do we're at a point
now where we need to like come together
as a country and you have a like large
platform to spread positivity but it
just seems like you go out of your way
to like ridicule people who are not the
same as you
like but buddy i gotta break it to you
like not everywhere is la
like there's a reason people are
conservative it's because we have family
values we have work ethic we like
firearms the firearm is similar so do
you think liberals don't have hold on
hold on do you think liberals don't have
family values or work ethics
well no no no
it's just it's different
why
i don't know why
okay
okay man i i hear you you know it's hard
though because you gotta i mean the
conservative media sphere right now is
as toxic as anything out there i mean
you look at crowder ben shapiro fox news
aon all these people are lit are the
most hateful people that have
that like exist in the media today no
yeah i i really wish i could hear you
better i can barely hear you all right
let me turn it up a little bit more
anyway thank you
yeah i mean
it's a vicious cycle right i guess
you're you're right in a way i don't
know what's the solution but i see that
uh
the people like ben shapiro crowder
fox news aon these people are viciously
hateful and it's not like tolerable hate
they're like bigots they hate immigrants
they hate gay people they hate trans
people this is the kind of hate that i
can't tolerate at all you know you can't
there's no mincing words with these
people so that's the majority of the
conservative
and like we said it's all culture war
and no substance i mean where am i wrong
right it's it's it's no you're
completely right it's too far
on on
on that spectrum for sure
but basically the i'm not i'm not a
hater i just want to call in and let you
know that there are conservative people
there are christian people who respect
the actual values of what it's supposed
to be like as a christian my main duty
is to love everyone for who they are
well it sounds like that's basically
what i'm trying to spread i love that
and i love you and i wish all the
conservatives were like you maybe it
sounds like i paint with the broad brush
i think it is the majority but i
acknowledge those people like you that
are good people good christians that
actually follow the teachings of jesus
not to just enrich themselves you know
what i mean so i wish there were i wish
that the conservatives were more like
you uh but but i don't think they are i
think the majority aren't
right and it's it's
it's it's real bad man well well i'm but
i'm glad you're out there
i'm still in awe that i got to talk to
you i'm so thankful that you know
you listened to me and respected what i
had to say
thank you just keep up good work guys i
love the show thanks johnny thank you
for listening yeah even though we're
constantly goofing on
the people that you love potentially and
uh i think you're one of the good ones
so i'm happy you're out there spread the
good word you know what i mean i i wish
conservatives were were more like you
and less like hating trans people
yeah i mean is it isn't america the one
place where people should be able to do
whatever they want a [ __ ] man hell
yeah really a [ __ ] man do you think
okay you know i'm not going to ask you
about abortion let's just end on a high
note
thanks bro take care let's end it yeah
yeah appreciate you take care i was
gonna be like do you think women should
so if you think women was like
let's probably not let's just be happy
that the call took a positive spin yeah
no i mean i yeah i i
we we we definitely uh paint with rod
brushes here on the show and it's
because it's a comedy show in here and
on leftovers as well and um
you know
well look i think i think it is better
to spend our focus on
and we mostly do
railing on you know media figures and
people with the platform exactly that
are espousing exactly
and vile things rather than focusing on
on individuals because i i'm without a
doubt there are a lot of people like
like johnny cash out there that um
that want to do right by their
countrymen and everything and we can
just disagree with how to go about doing
it without uh
hating them
yeah i mean obviously it's hyperbol uh
whatever
good point
thanks for calling here's helen who is
the
14th person ever
to survive a
black bear attack in minnesota history
that is a very specific accomplishment
but interesting is that true you're
the 14th uh ever
can you hear me okay i can hear you yeah
can you hear us oh my god great oh my
god i'm so nervous i love you guys hi
um tell me what happened yeah well
that's what i
okay well um
i'm 20 now and i also i don't live in
minnesota i live in new york so please
don't think that i live in minnesota
although i love minnesota i guess
um
i
have family there and i go every summer
to stay with them and they have like a
little cabin in the woods
um
and
they're a few years ago i think i was
17. yeah i was 17. a few years ago i
was walking in like this makeshift path
that my family had made
where they basically just tore down a
few trees um so you could walk through
like the woods
and i've been to this place since i was
maybe like seven or eight so
um
i have
walked this path a million times
and oh my god people saying i'm the
troll woman
cross check her voice
don't please don't encourage that go
ahead we're listening everybody's in the
chat
if you're goofing that's fine but if
you're serious please respectfully shut
the [ __ ] up and so i was walking through
there one day and i felt something just
clenched the back of my leg
and i turned around and it was just this
this black bear and black bears don't
usually attack you it's the brown ones
that do
so i was already confused and
i
i like blacked out and
then kind of kicked it off and then ran
up this hill
and i still have the scars and i do have
a picture to prove that this happened
if you guys want proof
but yeah i'm i had to get about eight
rabies shots and holy crap the local pd
had to come and they unfortunately had
to put down the bear
but you know you can really look up
ringo's a bear he's a real bear and um
no one has spotted him since
and if it wasn't ringo then they did
kill the wrong bear
um unfortunately so you were walking and
then he just swiped you like what
happened
well he he bit the back of my leg
you didn't hear him coming he just bit
you
no i heard nothing absolutely nothing
and i mean usually there's just like
little squirrels like roaming around in
the
leaves so i assumed that was the noise
but i felt the latch on and i i blacked
out and the next thing i remember i'm
running up a hill and i went to my
grandfather and i was like i think i was
bit by something and i was like maybe
it's a dog and then he looked at the
bite and then immediately took me to the
hospital
so what was the damage done to your leg
that's scary um if you want the picture
i don't know how i can send that to you
are you
uh are you on on discord
are you a member uh yeah i'm on the
discord uh sen uh dm it to me
i'm i'm on there don't put it on screen
just describe it to me okay
i can put it on screen and ian can just
not show it yeah if it's really gory
yeah okay
so yeah
how did you escape the bear did you did
the did the bear just decide he didn't
want to eat you after he took a little
nibble
yeah i don't really know either see um
okay wait i'm on the discord but i don't
know
it's fine i don't know how to message
you yeah it's okay
yeah well basically i'll describe it to
you i'm looking at it
um it's a gigantic it was probably the
size of
i'd say like a like a small dinner plate
um
and there are three teeth marks uh holes
in my leg
um a dinner plate that's pretty big
so was it just one he just took one
little bite at you and then was like uh
and then i must have picked him off
um
so you think you fought and survived
that's a good segue into it next that's
a great segue i'm sorry so you you
fought off a black bear and won
i did i did and apparently i mean i
looked it up right after and i think i
was the 14th um because there aren't
many
but yeah
actually what team it was black bear so
how did you get that figure 14
well this bear ringo is famous i'm
seeing uh a bunch of stuff about ringo
the bear in minnesota
damn poor ringo i just wanted a snack
well like she said black bears usually
aren't aggressive they're they're
relatively gentle was i wonder if he was
just starving or if he mistook you for
something or what happened because it's
i'm pretty sure with peace and love
he would have killed you if he wanted to
right i mean
he's a
bear
i'm gonna try and post this photo
discord or something because that's a
chat who would think that a mistake and
it's a fake story
sure post it
post it post it in the uh
in the well yeah post it wherever i'll
find it
this leads great into our next story we
wanted to do a conversation here amongst
the crew
which animals
could you take in a fight
now i know
i know that uh helen
could kill a bear i would never say that
for myself or you fight off a bear
easily she could kill a bear
black bears not that black bears are the
smaller variety right yeah i mean it's
all relative they're definitely still uh
i mean black bear is probably pushing
like 250.
i think i was a baby not baby but not
relatively young i think it was a young
bear ground
that poor bear don't you feel bad for
poor ringo i know he bit you
and tried to kill you no i do i i
couldn't even i couldn't look when they
did it i ran i didn't they had to by
like public law or something like if it
bit me it might have rabies and then
they oh
just a baby he just it's like it's like
he's getting a little nibble you know he
went in the cookie jar he took a cooking
from the cookie jar
exactly
like it was my fault not his well it
wasn't your fault i mean you're just
taking a walk
you were in his swamp yeah to be fair
do you feel like you have ptsd or
anything or you're fine
absolutely see i shop on your website
all the time and you guys put out this
shirt that has a bear on it like an
actual bear yeah and i had to just click
out i was logged off for the day
are you being serious you can't see
bears i'm actually serious
crazy i got to put trigger warnings on
our bear merch for you
thank you very much well no now i just i
browse with caution
so bears trigger you what about like
walking through the forest or hiking can
you do that or is that off the table
well i have not been back uh to visit my
family there since
well yeah i'd probably still that's
scary yeah i mean like you said
i'm sorry you went through that
but it's a good story it's okay i can
laugh at it now
did you post a picture of it
i think people in chat are still trying
to tell me how to
um all right well why figure it out
while you figure that out no worries
basically we're gonna say
last week um i made the bold claim of
saying i could beat a chimpanzee in a
fight i still think
that and yes i know this is a that was a
direct joke i missed making joke about
joe rogan but actually turned into an
interesting conversation i think i could
[ __ ] chimpanzee up maybe
maybe not 100 of the time but maybe a
50-50 where the battle is about to ensue
it's not like he gets a sneak attack and
rips my face off it's like let's go dude
we're in the arena 1v1 gladiator battle
where it's also i think i should get a
weapon frankly because the chimpanzees
they're made for comet they have crazy
claws and [ __ ] and humans fight with
weapons that's our evolutionary
advantage is that we're smart we got
weapons i mean that obviously that
changes everything if it becomes
that's like saying oh a rhinoceros
without his torn i mean humans we
evolved to use tools that's our
evolutionary advantage
maybe not a gun but a spear or some [ __ ]
a sharpened stick how about a sharpened
stick yeah something very like primitive
yes i guess i could get down with that
yeah
or just like a rock maybe like you can
pick up cave technology sure okay yeah
or like a sharpened stick i think that's
fair yeah because obviously humans are
defenseless
oh yeah yeah i was just curious yeah
absolutely you take care right you do
whatever you want ellen thank you be
good
the discord is telling me because they
can hear my things on stream oh okay
okay
all right take care how are you
watch out for those bears
keep your head low and
make sure to lock your food away and all
that bear stuff mm-hmm
yeah so
do we agree with the stick i mean that
changes the dynamic a lot maybe it could
be with and without a sharpened stick
it definitely changes the dynamic
significantly i
i do see your argument evolutionary
advantage that we have is our ability to
manipulate our environment so maybe we
should be able to we would have never
made it yeah that said i don't think a
sharpened stick is going to
do much in a fight against a chimp
i don't know dude
i feel like the chip will like catch it
or like stop it i was watching a
documentary about the woman that had her
face ripped off yeah by a chimpanzee
that she raised since a baby that she
thought that was sweet and loving
and the thing just went [ __ ] crazy
well she had her guard down
well it attacked you have a stick
and [ __ ]
yeah
we saw that worked out for uh siegfried
or roy exactly those were like yeah
exactly
they were having a bad day
you know
well anyway which anim so this is a this
is the poll that kind of launched this
is amazing you guys uh
so there's a poll conducted by you gov
is this a government-funded poll i don't
think so
is this what our tax dollars are going i
don't believe so
six percent of americans think they
could beat a grizzly bear in a fight now
that's ridiculous
wait wasn't there one
uh there should be a more detailed one
uh in the dock right below that um
[Music]
no what happened yeah there was a better
one than this i'll find it again anyway
so seven only 72 percent of americans
believe they could beat a rat in a fight
that's the part that really confused me
like
the only thing i can assume is that
there's like
a percent of people that are like i'm
just gonna run
when i see a rat but i'm talking a fight
to the death you got to put this thing
down dude you don't running is not an
option right a house cat
69 percent can't take a house cat in a
fight well you're kidding huh and we're
supposed to go to war with these wilkes
guys maybe you're deadly maybe those
people are like deadly allergic
i don't care if i'm allergic or not a
goose
61 percent can't take out a ghost and
we're supposed to fight the you the
russians
okay i
just found
a full survey
just a moment here
oh yeah zoom in on that okay so here we
go
all right so
um respondents were asked to choose
which of the animals would win in a
fight in a series oh wait no no this is
the animals fighting each other here's
the one with uh this is such a weird
pull like today yougov.com like y'all
really
we asked participants which animal would
beat the other ammo would an elephant
beat a tiger these are important
questions
all right so here we go a rat
uh yeah so 70 76 of men say they could
be and now
you see this they actually specified on
arms okay good they specified unarmed so
76 of men said they could beat a rat
unarmed 68 percent of women i am very
confused by this i do not understand how
24
of men could be like nah i couldn't i
couldn't take a rat what a joke
with the rat was master splinter
well then what changes everything yeah
obviously so a house cat is 74
64.
a goose is starting to take over i like
the other one this is confusing with the
genders i like that the goose there's
such a significant drop off in women
specifically saying uh
what dude you know if you have to you
just go
dude they're nasty i know they're nasty
but like i could also kill a toddler if
i had to whoa that's the thing when you
see the videos of like geese attacking
people and that how nasty they are
most people
they're not bloodlusted you know they
mean they they're trying to defend
themselves from the goose they're
attacking them and they're scared but
they're not like acting like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill this goose if you're
determined you're killing that [ __ ]
goose
every time let me tell you what's worse
than the [ __ ] goose itself is there
[ __ ]
gee [ __ ] is the most vile [ __ ] ever
just little pellets no
just smears everywhere and gets
everywhere it's horrendously bad really
what's your interaction with ghost [ __ ]
there's a place in la where there's a
lot of a lot of geese gooses goosai i
don't know the the plural for it
the best
so
there's [ __ ] everywhere kill them
with their bare hands here's the thing
though you'll try and drive
through them but they won't [ __ ] move
i don't i don't want to kill what i'm
saying that you take them out damn so
you want me to drive through it i want
you to kill as many ghouls as possible i
almost killed one one time because i
stepped in their [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's
awful it is
awful
gets everywhere
[ __ ] those keep in mind that we talked
about this on the show before but zach
hates birds i do he's got like a he's
just got a thing about birds any type
yeah so
it might be something more deep rooted
here
well 50 can't beat a medium-sized dog
this one i start to get
i mean dogs dogs can be strong a
medium-sized dog though like how how
much we talking 20 pounds like a
siberian husky
i mean it really depends i mean i could
beat a husky though you could argue that
a pit bull is a medium-sized dog and pit
bulls are small pit bulls are heavy
they're thick they're like 30 40 50
pounds
pit bulls are big
medium size is based on weight and i
would say maybe like 20 30 pounds
show me a picture of a 20 30 pound dog
you know
uh
medium
sized uh dogs are like basset hounds uh
pull it up oh siberian husky did come up
when i said how [ __ ] high scale
they're small they're petite
so that thing comes charging at you also
you can pull his hair like a mother they
got
yeah dude you go for the eyes you go for
the eyes
this is horrible
australian cattle dogs
you could go for the ears you could
stick your fingers in their ears even
but i would say eye gouge probably i
would order collie i would let the dog
kill me yeah me too i can't kill a dog
oh stop it you got to play the game you
can't be the [ __ ] sweetheart every
time i wouldn't yeah i don't kill you
don't think i love my dogs
but i could kill him if i needed to
we're talking about a bloodlusted
scenario here where it's you or this
[ __ ] dog man you gotta kill the dog
to save the world
right oh he's gonna i got it like a i am
legend situation you killed the daughter
the dog is look at this corgi that's a
[ __ ] i'm kid that dog is gonna die
dude it's so cute though yeah if we're
talking about
medium-sized dogs being like corgis and
stuff
yeah
they're their butts float like water
yeah i mean guys come on now a big dog
is a whole different question that would
be a battle to the death so like
a giant ass like great dane porgy bro
i don't know if i can kill you
i drop kicked that thing man
a schnauzer stop it whip it a whip it
what the hell why is that dog called
whip is not a is that when you like huff
nos yeah
hell that's that's what my dog bambi is
he's a he looks like a whippet yeah he's
a whippet
he's cute so yeah i mean medium dogs
easy
yeah i agree i agree
yeah
when i read that i was thinking a little
bit bigger consider medium
but
yeah i think there's like large and then
there's like extra large dogs great dogs
yeah there's like mass actually what's
funny is the extra large dogs are
probably not that tough either the great
super super super big ones mastiffs and
stuff like that there's like they're
like sloppy
special breed in russia they breed for
their prisons there that are just like
horses
bring out what they're called
those big ones are a little weak though
so whoa
yeah what what's the bro look at this
guy
that caucasian shepherd dog that dog's
probably pretty scary always angry
yeah
[ __ ] let me see next to the yeah
oh no no
look at that suits they got to put on to
take that that thing's taking you out
for sure you're going down i probably
wouldn't even be able to put up much of
a fight against that thing wait the bomb
dogs that kill bears
look on the left the left and the bottom
middle
that one
what is that real oh it's like a
perspective yeah it's closer to the
camera yeah just be next to the dog i
want to see how big it is i'm not trying
to look at clifford the red dog over
here
go down the one on the right where the
dog's standing up this one
no no no whatever who cares google
russian mastiff they're a huge russian
master what a beautiful dog i love dogs
so much
damn bro
so cute though it's so vicious bro it
looks like a pokemon that's what i need
at my house to keep people from [ __ ]
with me
can you imagine that'd be sick that's
what i need huh
somebody said that's ringo he faked his
own death
he's taken on an identity of his as a
new social security number
so funny click that one in the bottom
middle where he looks like he's wearing
a hat this one yeah what the hell dude
how do you keep a dog like that cool man
well they live in siberia so or
this one it says it's actually tibetan
that is yeah that's a tibetan they're
super expensive one of the most
expensive dogs in the world really
what's the price tag
so if i kill an expensive dog does that
make it cooler
uh
1500 to 5 000
that's not from a breeder
i mean for
that's for a normal one that's not what
most expensive i mean shredder was 80 or
no 1200 i've seen one sold for 1.9
million
1.9 million yeah here the golden hair
mastiff poppy is usually worth two
million dollars the the best breed
two million for what what do they do
they show them are they showed off yeah
it's competition
okay
i bet you a load of his jizz goes for a
high [ __ ] value
i'm serious
you know how much they ride you know
that horse they say horses is the most
valuable liquid on the planet i had a
whole debate about it well apparently
dog jizz is a close competitor
[Laughter]
all right so
images not worth that much we're saying
medium-sized dogs we everybody here is
saying they could take it easily yeah
yeah i don't think so and he did people
saying his docs doc sound was 2800 damn
all right so next up
we've got
uh where were we
an eagle now
like let's be honest 30 percent only
said they could beat an eagle that's
ridiculous i would [ __ ] an eagle up
i don't give a [ __ ] about his talents or
his be if i got hit one hand on him i
would tear his wings off his body do you
understand what i'm easier said than
done though i mean well i don't know how
i would get a hold of him but it seems
like it got a war like finishing move
yeah hell yeah i would i would well i
would go to war his ass grab him by the
if he the talons or if you could just
get one hand on him
boom dude feathers everywhere
i think it also depends on how he's
attacking you so and it depends on what
type of eagle because for example
just says eagle okay
this is like a vulture count is that an
eagle like these guys
oh what the [ __ ] these guys are kind of
intense
i don't know
the feathers make them look much bigger
but yeah it's kind of freaky look at
those [ __ ] claws yeah that's not a
good situation yeah and he's like coming
at you like 40 miles an hour and a dive
with those sticking out in front of him
i i don't know i don't know if i'm
taking that that's not a good situation
and that thing is scary uh yeah if you
yeah that's
i i don't know if it kill you to harm
you but i don't know if it would be
lethal enough i mean if you get a hold
of it it's gg i think you win i think
his legs look so strong though he might
be able to pull his leg out of your
grasp if he's drunk they're brittle bro
they're brittle yeah their bones are
hollow yeah i mean how much is it how
much does like a bald eagle weigh
probably like bald eagles five pounds
like seriously they weigh
six to 14 pounds
see 14 pounds is pretty good six pounds
death i mean that's probably the younger
one
let's see most
uh
uh a gr aggress or dangerous let's say
most dangerous eagle the most dangerous
eagle one is the most dangerous eagle
wait i'm just looking at love now i want
to see eagles
yeah someone said break his wings and
it's over it's true you just
those wings snap right into half boy
they sailing free they think they're so
lightweight they're so smug right i do
find it interesting that the
the eagle was so significantly um
only 30 percent yeah you know i'm saying
90 of the time i'm taking that dub
on the eagle i mean think about this not
to get ahead of ourselves but the next
category is large dogs which like we
were saying just looking at and
only a very small percentage more say
they could be an eagle than like a
people like a large dog i could not beat
like i don't think yeah i feel like a
large dog is significantly more
dangerous than a big eagle those dogs we
were looking at yeah they would [ __ ]
practically a bear
it would not it would be bad that would
be a very
that would be brutal i mean it would
just be brutal
yeah pull up one of those deadly ass
looking dogs again even a pit bull you
know pull up like a big pitbull yeah
probably like a 50 pound pit bull there
he is
i [ __ ] pit bull up
mr worldwide
i [ __ ] love
you think so
yeah i think he's short and old
you and you're short i'm just saying
height matters when you're fighting
nah dustin he's five seven five seven
broad [ __ ] snap his neck
in minecraft also how old is he
uh
he's probably about your age he is 41
years old he's 40. my what he's really
that young yeah
no way why would you think he was i
don't know i thought he'd been around
for so long i thought he's like 50. he's
been around the world he's been there
and done that dude yeah
you think you've been through some [ __ ]
he's been to motels he's been to hotels
he's been in the holidays he's been a
holiday he's definitely in better shape
than me but at five seven i think i'd i
could i could ragdoll him i just grabbed
his arm and go boom
he's quick though man
he's great he's probably quick like when
i went to his concert he was freaking
jamming he was fast
around nimble on his feet oh yeah hmm
swift
he might [ __ ] me up
all right what about a pit bull though
did i say you that guy weighs like a
hundred pounds
just saying you think pitbull weighs a
hundred pounds i do have five seven yep
an adult man
yeah
maybe 120 maybe one point just saying
i wish i had a way to know that
they're so cute pitbulls are so cute i
think pitbulls are adorable i think it's
very sad they're very small ones little
monsters but these are puppies or
something
um
show me like a scary type scary pitbull
okay like cujo like the dog from the
sandlot what the hell
what is wrong with people man
holy [ __ ]
yeah i mean hell nah
top
left hell nah oh i think that's gorgeous
but the thing is his legs are pretty
scrawny so like while
his jaw
will come down on you hard and not let
go let's say he gets on your arm okay
he's gonna
he's gonna
basically just you're not getting that
off your arm right so the thing is
you could go for the eyes
you could gouge out the eyes so he's on
your arm he's he's he's tearing your arm
up you have one hand you can gouge out
his eyes
i've heard that that's not effective
the the whole eye gouge thing
um like that won't stop them from
attacking
yeah i'm not sure what you could do he's
holding he's going crazy on your hand i
mean you could help his head that's not
gonna do anything the eyes he's probably
thrashing you're probably not gonna be
able to get a good hold you could
probably try to go up his ear might be
the best approach
as crazy as that is
she might be able to slip a finger
up his ear that might that that might
work
i bet if you flip the door over like
upside down it's gonna let go
what yeah
if you roll around and put the dog
upside down are you doing some brazilian
jiu jitsu on this dog yeah that's what
you should do when you're attacked by a
dog you should like take him to the
ground yeah body control dude
i know these things
i know these things so what are you
doing if he's thrashing around on your
arm yeah i mean i guess probably i i i
slammed him i nick bart barnett or
whatever he's called [ __ ] take my arm
i mean it is true that you probably
probably choking them out is probably
one of the better things you only have
one off cut off their ox they didn't
supply so you only have one hand and
that neck is so thick bro there ain't no
way you're choking him yeah
i don't know so you're gonna body slam
him
i hate to say these things up dogs i
love dogs i've had so many dogs but i've
ended like fights between two giant dogs
and i mean
i i think you can you can beat one of
these honestly
i don't think i don't know man
i stick a finger in his ear that's what
i'm saying in the ear
pit bulls are so sweet man
if you could see yeah
i i called them monsters earlier and i'm
sure the pit bull lovers out there will
hate me for that they're not all
monsters obviously i think they're i
think they're they're horrible animals
and they can be extremely sweet but it
is not untrue that they statistically
are more violent than many other breeds
unfortunately
well people well pit bull lovers would
say that's only because
more people owners
breed them to be violent and that may be
true but when you're walking down the
street and you see a pitbull that got
out of its house and is loose
statistically uh
you might want to run the other
direction
oh yeah dude oh man a loose dog running
towards you is not not good yeah just do
like what love would do and just [ __ ]
you know i got to say love i like your
what you said i think a body slam is the
best if he's going crazy thrashing on
your arm pick him up by the body and
just boom
that might be the best thing to do eh
yeah maybe
i think in that case i maybe i would win
if you get him to the ground start
bringing it to his kidneys
oh my god
you can get your feet in there
i'm just saying man this is a fight to
the death i've gotta i gotta think the
whole thing through you guys aren't
taking this seriously
we have no weapons i see all these
people saying uh
that that's [ __ ] and that's not true
show the statistics uh pitbull in 2019
pit bulls accounted for 91 percent of
all reported fatal attacks on other
animals 91 of all fatal attacks on other
dogs 76 of all fatal dog attacks on cats
and 82
because their pit bulls are doing 90
percent of all and i didn't say that
they're inherently that way i i
acknowledge that it may be the owners
that's crazy but this is these are facts
i'm sorry if it's upsetting but how much
people's attack people someone said my
strategy is the same for each animal
just bring them to the ground and
[ __ ] up
yeah no that's not true i like my
strategy with the dog body slam to the
kidneys the only way i could deal with
the dog is the same way will smith did
just in a headlock crying my eyes out
like a little [ __ ] what dog did he kill
he killed his dog because it turned to
one of those [ __ ] walkers what kind
of dog was it oh
i don't i don't remember it was the
tournament i remember the dog's name for
some reason it was a german shepherd
right and i am legend yeah
i don't know you could pin a dog down
that easily like that
i think you can yeah that's what i was
thinking more just pin it down
yeah well
um pitbulls are not more dan is taking
on the pitbull community jesus i said i
love pitbulls i think they're adorable
and i've known many pipples they're
sweet dogs
it's not psychotic to acknowledge that
they attack people sometimes that's
crazy though that they they're 90 of
animal violence
just one breed
and again maybe it's because people buy
pit bulls to be violent and they're
raising them you know and training them
to be attack dogs that's fine you know
that's a different conversation but
whether or not
a lot of animal attacks are perpetrated
by pit bulls is
it's it's just it's just a fact sorry
well
dan has beef with the pitbull people now
i don't
i really don't moving on moving on
but like if you're talking any large dog
bigger than pitbull not get murdered
like easy easy murder you guys think you
could take one of those does russian
prison dogs hell no
oh [ __ ] no love you seem confident
not the biggest one though definitely
not
i mean those are basically just bears
yeah
so the next one is the the controversial
one chimpanzee which i infamously said i
could take a chimpanzee
only 17 percent though say they could
[ __ ]
pull up a chimpanzee let's see pull up a
small chimpanzee okay let's start there
that's a small adult chimpanzee we do
have this uh i'm not looking for king
what was the guy from the jungle book
the king monkey
uh
king unga bunga or whatever the [ __ ]
king louie king louie not trying to
fight king lure here this one's small
he's so jacked
oh my god
dude you hit the g bro do you lift
damn that look how jacked that little
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] is
where's your hair dude do you think you
could take that
i don't know man
when you see it like that you know it's
so agile and strong that's intimidating
dude but but think about this you have a
sharp stick
the thing is he's got like not only his
he's got claw like teeth like sharp
teeth yeah
yeah he could bite you he could scratch
you
and he could attack with his hands and
feet
no
way no way
that thing
that thing would kill me can i see a
close-up of their claws please dan
they have fingers oh they don't have
claws can i see their fingers no but do
they have like sharp nails and stuff no
not not like not like you're thinking no
so their their fingers are similar to
ours okay and can i see um
so how do you rip off a woman's face
then like how's that they eat it well no
he clawed it man like he just pulled it
just grabbed the cheek and pulled really
hard and the jaw i mean they're strong
dude it's so scary yeah i mean
oh i got pictures of pitbull if you guys
are curious if you guys want to keep
sizing oh i didn't realize we were
getting so much info on the general
yeah this is good stuff here
whoa this is an eagle talon
i mean eagles are basically dinosaurs
that's not good yeah
bad
and they're like sharp too like knife
sharp you know what i mean
you think you can [ __ ] that up love i
don't know
that looks pretty rough
it's tough dude i'm pretty sure that
that dude might lift me and drop me off
a cliff or something
and what about this guy
oh he's a [ __ ]
watch pitbull's friends gonna come stalk
me now
so
i'm looking at chimps now
so these these teeth i tell you are
these are a bad situation to be in
those canines
i don't know man
are you rethinking this a little i am i
am rethinking it but
now here's a finger see they have
golly man stick your finger they have
huge hands
those those nails look pretty strong
oh i'm sure it would contribute it's
just that they're not like they're not
uh claws you know what i mean it's it's
not it doesn't come to a point this is
basically how the fight begins
this is them tapping gloves before they
fight exactly
okay and does anyone think they could be
a chimpanzee
nobody eh except me you're asking the
crowd or the audience i'm asking you
guys no uh no no no i'm gonna pass i'm
fighting the champ
sharp sharp stick or not it's like hard
no dude pick them out
let me think about this
that wasn't even a debate
what what's one way i could get at him a
gun
could i choke him out
could i body slam him i mean you'd get
that i got you get a few good hits in
there like i'm not even doubting that
but i'm absolutely i don't think
punching or anything is gonna do
anything i just would just get on you
man and just
by the way this is not a big chimp damn
there's like a massive one there's
smaller ones
like here's a smaller one
not that it looks any better for me but
it still looks
god those teeth are [ __ ] yeah i mean
he would kill me with one good bite
i don't see any way where i win this
fight
yeah i think i think it's done can i
kick him in the balls he's a primate
nah
well maybe but that might just piss it
off more
you think i could choke him out
i mean if you get a good grip on him
yeah but
he's probably so agile though you know
how humans can't get at you and they're
getting choked out he could oh yeah he
would [ __ ] you right the flexibility is
a big advantage what's this rumble in
the jungle oh that's what it's called
rumble in the jungle
so 22
oh we skipped the king cobra i just
realized no it's coming up
king cobra is next on this list
oh maybe your list is in a different
order
yeah so 22
of men think they can take out a
chimpanzee
well do you think like um
you think like a
prized fighter could take out a champ
like a bit like the mountain the
mountain could probably [ __ ] chimp up
that guy's strongest out
maybe
yeah he could do it yeah shaquille
o'neal
just pure weight maybe in size in his
prime maybe
because then he would be able to do the
just grab him by the arms and rip his
ass absolutely male chimp wait
yeah can we make this happen if we
crowdfund a bunch of money
like a big adult chimp is about 150
pounds yeah i mean are you serious yeah
delete me from discomfort you can't one
for one it with 150 pounds oh i'd be i'd
be absolutely [ __ ] yeah you can't one
for one with a human at all because
their their muscle is way more powerful
than ours so
dude 150 no i'm out
dead 10 out of 10.
dead 10 out of 10.
all right well let's move on i i'm sorry
guys i'm sorry i let you guys down but
there's just no way yeah no i'm glad
that you're able to you know there's
just no way make your mistake and grow
and
learn hey where'd the list go eye head
open though god damn it
what's the same this it sourced from the
same thing i liked mine better oh and
yours i like mine better
okay here it is
all right so king cobra i mean
it's just about not getting bit
no tools though i mean that's
yeah i mean you see people that are
experts at snake handling deal with it
all the time um but yeah they always
have that little
that little stick that they can kind of
like grab them and move behind them with
now i have seen snake handlers who have
a way of kind of sneaking around them
and like
getting them behind the the face
definitely
there is a chance i think there's way
more of a chance of taking a cobra than
a chimp i agree like vastly more which
is strange that they're so close on the
uh
how about a king cobra way let's get
some stats let's get some pictures
probably just a few pounds right october
kids spit it's venom up to 6.5 feet away
damn what it's spinning
up to 13 pounds well don't they have to
inject it what what are they spitting at
me for it can get in your there's like a
spinning cobra like a certain species of
it like spits it in your face
and that in itself blinds you yeah and
it i mean their venom is can take out
spitting on me yeah so
yeah some some have like acid when
they're spit
i mean i think it's called
i guess the real question is which which
is deadly or the chimp or the cobra the
chimp definitely the chimp i mean
obviously if a cobra bites you and and
gets you a good poison that's that's
real bad but i i think the chimp is
deadlier but but assuming it's
bloodlusted like it's going all out
trying to kill you i love you so
bloodlusted bro
there's anti-venom for the cobra like
you if let's say you get bit you there's
i think this assumption is that you're
you're in the wild dude you don't have
any like you're unarmed you're you're
just mono imano monoi snake i think a
chimp versus king kerber would be like a
double double ko you know the chimp
would definitely kill right but it would
probably bit a lot in the process yeah
that's true
i don't know that thing's pretty big man
i i don't think you could i don't think
i could restrain that maybe you'd have
to get both hands right behind the head
that just seems so hard to do
you don't even have to get behind the
head you just have to because you just
have to grab it by the by the neck yeah
the way he's holding it right now he for
sure could get bit you would you would
want to like be grabbing it by the neck
basically you'd have to be really far up
there yeah that's so scary can you
imagine yeah that's the thing oh nasty
pig
it's it's this is a uh
this takes a high dex uh score i think
to win yeah strength strength isn't
really helping you here i think you you
would have to finesse this
real well
so could i take a king cobra if i had to
fight a king cobra
i think there's
a small chance i could get him but but
not a good one
i mean you're in the jungle right
you save you kill this cobra to save the
world what's the chance you've come out
victor
you have to
for everybody in the world bloodlust as
dan says bloodlust it's more of a
finesse though not bloodlust
why when i say bloodlust i just mean in
the sense that like
you're not trying to restrain you're not
trying to
you know pin or whatever you're like
you're both trying to kill each other
you're doing everything in your power to
kill each other it's full bloodlust come
on guys i think there's a chance i think
you got a shot i think i i
definitely would say much better chance
than a chimp like chimp it's pretty much
zero shot not happening cobra
is probably still
you're gonna lose the majority of the
time but
with a little luck
and some finesse i think you could do it
with your finger i'm thinking maybe both
would die right okay
before you die of the poison
how would you even kill that thing with
your bare hands like i think you'd have
to bite it dog that's my only you'd bite
into it not like how
can you twist it like a [ __ ] soda pop
top bro they're like [ __ ] like a
snapple it's a large
twist actually like a snapple dude i
mean
if we're if you're not worrying about
getting bit or like you've already been
bit and now you're just like trying to
take it out before you go down i don't
think it's actually that hard to do they
weigh 10 to 14 pounds you grab it and
you slam it against the ground over and
over again you know what i mean you can
just rag to hold that [ __ ] it's
a good point yeah yeah now it's gonna be
biting you while that's happening and
you're probably [ __ ] but i don't i
think in any scenario you would be able
to kill it i don't know it can slither
away those things are pretty fast one
two they could wrap up on your ass
i don't think cobras do the constricting
i don't think i could be wrong i'm not a
snake expert but i don't think they're
they're constrictors
okay well there's a shot
i'm saying there's a shot there's a shot
there's a shot next kangaroo
all right this one's pretty interesting
because
you know
we've looked at pictures of kangaroos
here on this podcast and they
they're built like a chimpanzee actually
they're built different they're they're
jacked bruh but i've also seen people
fight a kangaroo i saw a dude there's a
video in australia you could pull up he
just straight up punches him in the face
and walks off we got claims last time we
showed that video oh we did [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah that's funny
look at this [ __ ] chad you said what
might
you what mate
bro what is this posture even like
i i just kangaroos don't make sense to
me what what are they i agree it's such
a weird animal what are they they're
marsupials marsupials yeah and is that
related to a human or
well they're matte
wait
is it marsupial a mammal or is that a
whole different thing
because they have fur they're a mammal
right they're a mammal yeah yeah
i mean are they related to humans in
what way like in a way a dog is i mean
they have very more human like
tendencies like i guess like the chimp
no they're not chins i know
it's interesting because
i don't they don't make sense to me but
well they're weird they have like a
specific uh biological lineage from
australia right that's why all the
australian animals are weird as hell
and they have a [ __ ] pouch like
what
and they stand on their tail
it's just they don't make sense to me
man
yet they're real
could i kill i don't think i could
listen i definitely couldn't kill a
kangaroo
but i don't think a kangaroo can kill me
either
i think it would be a
i think it'd be a draw
lifts up those legs i don't know
they just don't seem they seem like they
just let you go i think they have this
like crazy ability to because their
their their legs are
super powerful and they can like
lean back on their tail and [ __ ] get
you in the gut and i mean we saw that
dude fight the kangaroo he socked him in
the face and walked off it was awesome
animals died
i mean we have a surprisingly high
percentage of australian fans uh
uh
they probably know better than anybody
because it's just a fact of life down
there i mean are you ready
it's like super common people get [ __ ]
up by kangaroos all the time they like
just roam there
i googled it how many people died by a
kangaroo and apparently over 18 years
there's for 10 years there's been 18
deaths caused by kangaroos but most of
those are
almost all of us are
from like vehicle crashes and stuff
oh wow so
there is
from what i can tell no recorded deaths
by kangaroo they're good dudes what
they're like frat bros you know they get
a they toss a little down but at the end
of the day they're good dudes they'll
let you walk away
huh how much you're growing how much a
uh
an adult kangaroo way
maybe he's looking it up oh this
australian says
kangaroos can't walk back i just was
about to read that comment
40 to 20 200 limbs
between 40 and 200 limbs so what
somebody said they do kill people what
did you say
what'd you say
wait what did you say
i don't know what i say
you said libs
i said limbs
what's a limb
i read it i read it wrong
[Laughter]
you saw lbs
you really want to do this right now
we're really going to do this you know
what i'm with jeff watch your back i was
at first genuinely confused
40 pounds that's pretty small
maybe
did you say lbs listen i got air parents
that's how they used to read it to me i
know that's how they used to say it i
know it's wrong i corrected myself
immediately
i didn't even hear what you said he said
he said 40 libs
yeah i see instead for the abbreviation
for pounds i mean i get the compelling
lb's i don't know why the [ __ ] they
write lb it's not your fault
it sure feels like it
i'm playing
sorry
i genuinely didn't know what you said at
first i was i was confused
hey i'll look that up why
it's a disgrace to ap
why is pounds abbreviated as lb's
or pounce in rome
unit of measure was libra pondo
he weighs 40 libra pandas yeah
anyway let's get on with it you know i
mean look kangaroo
i couldn't kill a wolf one wolf
no crocodile no gorilla no an elephant
eight percent of people think they could
[ __ ] kill an elephant does somebody
want to explain that to me
how can you kill how can a man kill an
elephant
a lion
grizzly bear obviously not
how does anyone think they could kill an
elephant that one just seems so weird to
me
yeah i don't know i
yeah
and unarmed specifically yeah i
maybe by
i'd like to meet that guy i don't i
don't know i don't know how that's
working i i don't see any scenario where
you could even climb up his ass stance
ventura
did some damage rhino right
pretty hot in these rhinos
all right well that was fun
[Applause]
what else we got on this [ __ ]
document for you to watch real quick i
think ab could beat a kangaroo not in a
fight but a moonwalking competition
since they can't walk backwards
moonwalking competition oh we could oh
he could also that's not even fair if
they can't walk back well this
[ __ ] can moonlight we'll
moonwalk like that's true yeah i mean
maybe he's got the moonwalk
figured out is that true
i can't even walk yet let's see it
i can't right now
what the [ __ ] bro you can moonwalk you
can't you're not moonwalking
you should be walking everywhere not the
right floor right it's a car
if i could moonwalk i'd be why i'm
walking in and out every day
you don't you don't need to walk when
you can walk
who needs roads when you can fly in the
words of uh neo or or back to the future
that's where we're going we don't need
roads yeah
[Laughter]
uh what else is in here is good guys
oh m or more machine gun kelly cringe
this is fresh
wait i haven't seen that
machine gun they shouldn't have let
machine gun kelly anywhere near a
basketball port after this debacle
what's the context here
so this is at the uh all-star game they
have a celebrity game beforehand
and uh mgk didn't do so hot
so i'm assuming you only sign up if you
know how to play if you're like good at
basketball or because is it open to
anyone like
because he did not perform well ian may
know better than me
i don't keep up with some standards here
uh i mean i think it's people that at
least think that they can play that sure
yeah
well here's
here's machine gun kelly
what what you say what did you say there
i seen his arm and i decided
his muscles got muscles yeah
that that's bad
like stiffing on a shot is not the worst
but that's bad
bro
dude
[Laughter]
he's trying so hard too it's just
[Laughter]
i was hitting those shots when i was 12
man
playing like uh philip seymour hoffman
one movie
he i mean look it's a long game he's
probably a good basketball player here's
this is the new ethan i'm sure he's
really good at basketball his music's
cool
he's got a lot of fans he brings a lot
of positivity his fashion is awesome i
love his tasks his tattoos are so cool
his jersey's sick
when
he's got a lot of when he's in a
boardroom he likes to get up on the
table and dance i mean that's rebel
behavior that's cool
he's got passion why the [ __ ] did smash
mouth comment
now you all need to shut your mouth you
all need to be shut mel we haven't
forgotten we haven't forgotten steve
hardwell or whatever [ __ ] your name is
smash mouth really in the replies
dropping laughing emojis bro
come on now
wasn't he the guy at the like uh
the motorcycle rally
he was but more importantly
this you smashed my house just see smash
bal perform live at a local beer and
wine festival
when i say this is the most chaotic show
i've ever seen in my entire life
i have no words at no point was the
sound balance
unintelligible speech
this is what happens when you become
famous on like three songs from shrek
[Music]
bro where are you right now
[Music]
yeah
good stuff
should we watch
um
um
um i'm looking for something good
two videos that are pretty good pilot
which ones this one this one one right
here oh the cnma one no not that one
above that one
you want to watch this whole thing i
actually watched this already
it's pretty good and then below it
is
when memes collide
so sienna may
went on
uh
the bff podcast center for doing video
forensics was retained to perform
pause this pause this please this time
stamp we can't watch that
what is it
so
she brings in a lawyer and a video
forensic analysis
analysis i'm sorry and
he
looks at the video that she allegedly
essayed someone in
and he is trying to say that it's not
real he's saying that it's altered and
wait dude give me a break right under
this link right here i have a screenshot
of his conclusion if you want to look at
that these are the three points that he
makes dude that is so embarrassing where
do you find this guy
who even tried to
the video is not original the video has
been heavily altered the video provides
no context to the events well does it
provide context or is it altered
pick your lane
so how did they respond were they like
this is crazy
uh
you know sort of yeah dave porquay has
to be careful when it comes to uh yeah
it's a little close to home for him
but she went on this podcast and she
brought a lawyer and they uh
here let me pull this apart it's quite
good
she brought a lawyer and a forensic
expert
which is so wild man
um you guys don't know she
was accused of essaying her
her friend jack wright
and a video came out of her on top of
him when he was drunk passed out she's
saying it's fake which is so insane and
i was saying before josh joined we got
quite the setup i don't even know how
it'll look when we do it because we have
two
lawyers right your your lawyers are on
here wow yeah um so i actually have
my lawyer here her name is julie
gerschick and then i have a video
forensic expert and he's basically just
gonna be talking about the video
um
but
yeah okay so
were you convinced at all by his
analysis of the video it seems so insane
absolutely not no
maybe can i listen i'll just i'll not
show the video
and whatever [ __ ]
boy [ __ ]
there's one video i've been wanting to
watch with you guys for a while
but it's kind of rage inducing it's like
the most obnoxious video i've ever seen
rage inducing it is
it's uh this guy called named
um
danny mullen
and for christmas he went to
las vegas with all of his friends oh
and just started harassing everyone on
the street yeah i saw it's just horrible
it's just it's so mean and weird
do they drop the c word or anything in
this i think that a lot of that kind of
stuff i would be careful [ __ ] i could
screen it real quick yeah it's not that
long
yeah i was i was pretty shocked by this
vulgar you know
oh my god
oh my god just at random people
so like
she should get punched in the face right
well
easy
well i mean
let's say no one should be shocked if
that happens that's a much better way
of putting it by the way cruising around
with two 40s taped to her hands class
act all the way
by the way the context i saw the whole
video people got super angry and they
took it down they were taking turns
just insulting people so this is just
hers i don't know why
they targeted hers because they were all
equally obnoxious right it wasn't just
well i know why
uh
you guys look like the same people but
five times
how is that funny that that's like
so
i don't know man
[Music]
says the belligerent girl yelling at
at random people with 40s uh taped her
hand i think if anyone needs a life
coach oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god i can't even keep track of the
chaos anymore oh my god
[Laughter]
nice
i mean and then when people get pissed
they get like hostile
yeah i mean
bizarre
send them to the front lines i am in
punxsutawney
sorry i just opened up his channel this
guy has half a million subs yeah he's
big he's real popular
and it's all very bad in fact we should
browse this channel
he goes this is why you carry bear spray
because you're want
yeah content court could be in order
definitely
interesting
what's his name mullen danny mullen
let's see
i see
i'm just looking over his channel let's
look at uh atom22 on here we got uh most
popular
how big is your penis
[Music]
can you say that
can you [ __ ] say that how big is your
penis
extreme sign holding oh god
he's just in the thumbnail it's a sign
of him holding it saying the r word
the girls like their ass licked
that's a good question
girl deep i don't think this guy's
popping off these are his most viewed
girl deep throats banana is one of his
most viewed
awesome just two minutes long
you
show us your tits is the title of this
video
some high level [ __ ]
i took penis enlargement sex with the
prostitutes
i mean anyone can do that okay that's
just straight up like everyone has
access to that service
that's your funny ass title bro
okay what on
so there's 12 year olds watching this
basically i took penis enlargement pills
dude
we got into a brawl on the fourth of
july cool
we got arrested at the mini golf course
yeah i'm pretty sure that was
fully justified here's a video of me
basically being a menace to society
kissing black girls
yeah it's just straight up kissing black
girls whoa extreme contest
what the [ __ ]
yo you know um oh god you know
this is like some unfound uh
on tap create frank invasion [ __ ] yes
yeah this is untapped cringe right here
you really got a video called kissing
black girls okay king
should i click it
i think maybe we should
do a deeper dive on this i did not
realize there was such a rich seam of uh
cringe content
making girls chew tobacco kissing oh
here he is kiss making out the 80 year
old
okay this i'm interested in patiently
this guy may have been in the popcorn
i think this guy is a direct offspring
of prank invasion it's
seems kind of weird day drinking in
texas let's go
drag queens terrorize san francisco
sorry sacramento big filming weekend we
thought we'd jet out to san francisco
for a little bit we're gonna maybe wear
female clothing in san francisco people
are afraid to offend somebody they
perceive as transgendered so i feel like
this is going to be our free pass to say
and do whatever the [ __ ] we want four
hours oh yeah it's gonna be huge is he
wearing a [ __ ] lou reed shirt as he's
doing this transphobic [ __ ] nonsense
oh the irony that is
unbelievable
these guys are such pieces of [ __ ] this
is gonna be our free pass to say and do
whatever the [ __ ] we want for three
trans
trans people can do whatever they want
like use a bathroom with the gender they
identify with those
privileged pigs i love when conservative
people act like trans people are the
most privileged in the world
trans people get a free pass do whatever
they want you're four hours oh yeah it's
gonna be a huge one dude where's the
women's section jack what do you think
of his friend's outfit
you know he's just fire zach what are
you trying to say a dog
can you go back a frame ethan sure
what are you trying to say
it does look like effect that is exactly
there's nothing wrong with it yeah yeah
he looks good look he could be a piece
of [ __ ] but he's hype as [ __ ] dude yeah
look i'll i rock no you rock it man you
rock it it's just funny
this the shirts are unbuttoned like the
same exact button too
zack's a little lower actually
damn afraid to offend somebody they
perceive as transgendered so i feel like
this is going to be our free pass to say
and do whatever the [ __ ] we want for
three or four hours oh yeah it's gonna
be a huge one dude where's the i'm gonna
skip this part guys where you shop
michael cool deny this man i get it like
i get it you're buying clothes that are
made for women
that's so crazy
like except once if you want me like
just put it on and do the video
i don't care that you went to ross and
put a but
okay
i look like a bowling alley prostitute
look at this blue grimace from
mcdonald's it's our 16th birthday he
wants to start drinking not old enough
to [ __ ] but i'm old enough to suck and
you can believe that hey would you
that's disgusting there's kids right
there why you do why are you saying that
in front of
families guys are such a degenerative
16th birthday
not old enough to [ __ ] but i'm old
enough to suck and you can believe that
hey would you ladies be willing to put
on some makeup make him look like a lady
who'd be sucking [ __ ] behind the chucky
so this are they doing like a like an
impression of what trans people sound
like
hey i want to suck everyone's dick
i mean it seemed to be
the angle is like oh look at these crazy
tolerant san franciscans we can be as
outrageous as we want i saw you doing
that in vegas and nobody did anything
there either
and also you can just edit out anytime
anybody says something to you and
probably will so
right
exactly
i want to look like for 15 us dollars
you could defecate on my chest right you
guys are killing it thank you
okay get on with it guys you want to
make a video or what no no no i'm good
bud
oh so you want to go meet up your
apartment is what you're saying yeah
let's go yeah sure after i go and pick
up my friend how's that who's your is
your friend a guy yeah you guys are gay
no no what are you it's a girl no it's a
guy
i can't comprehend a man-on-man hangout
that doesn't involve sucking dicks so
you're going to break this down play by
play touch my nipple and that's going to
be your intro kind of a jimmy lee level
like yeah man on the street
as well
yeah i mean if these guys can succeed i
don't see why jimmy lee can't
it's not even
you know what i mean yeah
jimmy is probably funnier than these
guys
i actually agree like ironically
what do you all think about uh holding
up in a fully bitten motel room for a
few hours wow that is the last thing i
want to do let's go see if we can get a
hotel room look at these san francisco's
not beating my ass immediately for being
a douche what [ __ ]
up and then beat the [ __ ] out of a young
peasant boy do you guys offer any
outfits that would meet that job
description what's up dude how are you
what's up man how are you doing right
now
where are you
you know you're jumping
where are you going
you got nothing better to do
sir now where are you going sir sir
don't be like that man that love to a
condition like it was dead raise the
quest
okay
hate him
epic
so that's pretty interesting something
to look into yeah
all right well
um
this is it
that's it that's the show
damn anything else we should touch on
while we're here
um
[Music]
we got some new shoes to look at
some new shoes
rusty oh i did see these
rustic footwear
yeah these are fire they seem really
they seem really uh
useful
[Music]
practical thai fashion it's cool
i specifically like
i like those that vibe he looks kind of
like uh i mean he does give me dark
souls a little bit
oh
you're right
kind of looks like cp3o
that's the yeah yeah that one looks like
c3po
but i could definitely see by the way do
these look like high fashion people in
the front row
i mean probably her
the people that are into it
i mean
you know what i'm not even going to
pretend to understand this [ __ ] world
it's baffling to me
let's analyze the people in the crowd
because it's important
i guess it could be anyone but she's the
editor of vogue magazine
it could be
[Music]
brush that looks like my aunt
all right
[Laughter]
fun times eh
good time guys
that's the show
i hope you enjoyed it remember we're on
baby mode so keep expectations low for
us for a little bit
just lower your expectations that
expectation is low i mean that's just
good advice in general in life just just
in general not just for the show but in
everything in life yeah
elton john
don't shoot me
i'm the piano i'm the only piano player
this is still available teddyfish.com
still available
i thought it was all sold out already
not this one huh some stuff's still
available
don't shoot me i'm only the piano player
fair enough cool will do or won't do
kind of scared to go home now because of
uh
tito tito jackson or whoever
whatever uh jeff's friend's name is
i don't want to say his name right now
did you actually think his name was okay
okay i just trying to think is that an
italian name tito
afraid
there's uh yeah that shirt's still
available just for the record it's sold
out though in large
goddammit god damn it oh god
people are sending me crazy danny mullen
stuff we'll have to okay good yeah keep
the danny mullen stuff coming
just learned about this guy
so um
see on wednesday guys
thanks for watching like and subscribe
like and subscribe
hit that bell smash that like button
teddyfresh.com
leave a comment
tell us
share it on social media double smash
quadruple smash
tag us on social media with a screenshot
of you liking this episode
we'll retweet you follow you
yeah
give away follow for follow we'll
intent you a giveaway for tesla if you
subscribe
i'll come to your house and shake your
hand how about that wow come to your
house and invite you
nope didn't promise that
i am i am promised oh ethan will do that
okay
or conor lingus you if that's what
you're into but i doubt it i don't think
any women want anything for me i feel
like the gays maybe but
maybe not i don't think anyone wants
anything to do with me
all right you know what
let's send it
to you do me a favor end it
mute his mic
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you